foreign
[Music]
okay can you guys hear me if you can
type pig in the chat Pig
type pig in the chat
oh my gosh okay so yes
Pig
okay now type
snack in the chat
snack
in the chat
oh my God okay it's working all right
streaming
mostly because my setup is not ideal
um okay so I'm gonna try
something
okay Pig snack all right now
now type
I don't know what to tell you to type I
give up I'm trying to set up
all of the things my friends I'm so
excited about this though
so yeah I'm just I'm here
Just Gotta Give me a hot minute
I know you can't see me I don't want you
to see me yet I'm not ready for this
do you guys hear like double audio or
anything or like what's up
music sells doubled I thought so okay
how about now
type iPhone 15 in the chat
no okay
yes doubled music okay I think I fixed
it
[Music]
fortnite is spelled incorrectly in my
title
oh my God who how do I
are you serious
I don't even know how to change it
oh
okay do you guys want to see me this is
what we're dealing with right now
um
I am so sorry to everyone who's trying
to figure out
what's happening
um hi so I'm gonna be playing here very
soon I spelled fortnite wrong guys I'm
sorry I don't even I honestly don't even
know how to change it I'm so
so silly
I stream like once a year
I so oh my God what an idiot for oh geez
I mean are we surprised so the problem
also is this light is so bright I can't
see anything on my screen
let's Spell fortnite correctly
and then we can
figure some stuff out
okay let's see here's my channel here's
my stream we love that
stream manager this is where we want
this is what we want I'm halfway off the
screen
there we go edit stream info
yep
four nine
I can't I can't see it my screen is so
little okay here we go
okay we've done that
we've done that
so can you guys can you hear me you can
see me
is my voice delayed
we don't know
uh Justine twitch gamer streamer was out
of my 20 oh my God that's so loud
how do I how do I
how do we how do we stop that
can I do a Lego Stream
Maybe
oh no
so
the
oh boy
I have one of those uh the tracking
insta360 cameras
so now
it tracked me because I put my hand up
it's good to know that it works
so there we are we're back
so you hear me you see me
do a flip
I can't do that
I don't know if Jenna's gonna join us
I've had a I woke up at
4am today on the East Coast
got on a plane flew here
I'm not I don't know
I don't know I'm gonna I'm gonna play
the game now though
so
for those of you that don't know I guess
I'll start the Stream
I should title it setup stream I really
should let me just get in here and then
we can start this
I don't have too much time tonight
but tomorrow
I'm gonna do a like a longer stream
stream of some of my friends
if I can get my friends to
to stream with me we will see but
tonight I just kind of had to set
everything up because
I haven't streamed in so long
so I uh
okay do I not have
do I have game audio
no because I muted it
do we hear double audio
hopefully not
I don't even know if I can handle
playing with someone else right now
because that would involve
me getting on Discord
and then adding in another audio source
and I'm not sure if I trust myself to to
be able to handle that at my current
mental state right now
um
game audio is working
I do have a server I don't ever go on it
but I usually only use it when I stream
had Discord
it's called same brain
[Music]
I think we can start now
I'm excited okay let me get this all
ready
okay
here we go
photo for Instagram
[Music]
please hold while I do this okay
you'll see that on Instagram soon
um
[Music]
I can't wait to play this I can't wait I
think I lowered my volume oh man did I
hello how's that is that better
foreign
ing right now
on my new iPhone 15 Pro Max have you
seen it
guys the amount of videos and content
content that we have uh been posting and
editing
it's been a wild time so thank you for
all of the support
and I've been loving watching all of
your reactions and everyone who's uh
opening up their phones today
hyped
[Music]
all right
um I got the iPhone before launch
because
Apple sends them out to people to review
and I
I'm cut off of the screen again so
I have to send it back because it's not
my phone
which is so sad
whoa look at that
let's maybe go back a little bit
lower game audio a little bit okay okay
I can do that
how's that is that better
okay
I'm so excited
about this
and I'm going to tell you the story of
how this all came to be
here in a second
but you just gotta wait because I'm slow
at posting
did I
should I write what did I write on
Twitter
foreign
I thought I wrote
I don't know what I thought I wrote
second I can't wait to tell you guys the
story it's gonna be great
like this is how long it takes me to
post like one thing you guys don't even
know
it's really pathetic
okay
put a little
Channel link here
I forgot I could do that
well it's not letting me so whatever
okay
okay it's happening we're ready I'm I
see the chat
so robot Ranch
oh my God okay how do I turn that down
because that's going to drive me insane
[Music]
oh my God it's so loud
I don't know I don't know okay anyway
story time
um
it's a robot Ranch was a name that I
came up with
two three maybe like three four years
ago and
I originally had this concept of it
being a reality show on like a real farm
with like robots like it was wild that
never ended up happening because the
pandemic happened and then basically
everything fell apart and then I I know
that a lot of you guys don't like nfts
but I drew an entire nft collection and
it was gonna be titled jpig like J Pig
like JPEG and never ended up
releasing those I will at some point and
this has nothing to do like the jpeg in
this game has nothing to do with nfts so
don't like
freak out
um
and no they meant Bobby because that
it's like objective like obstacle like
obstacles I also thought it was supposed
to be Lobby so I
I see you so jpig
is a character now in robot Ranch and I
voice the character so there are those
jpeg there's jpeg so I don't know let's
just freaking play is anybody else
playing
hello this is Tech today is IT Tech
today
it is today
um
good to see you good to see you I look
forward to our next event hanging out at
the bar where I drink water
um
let's play
I've got about like an hour
ish
oh my gosh you're playing it
Nexa next H all right let's go we're
playing my fastest time on PC is 13
minutes
not great
I've only played the final version of
this a few times most of the the ones
that I've played were like pre-release
so this is like final final
AC I have not given up on the nft
madness I have not I just realized that
none of you guys like it so I'm just
gonna be over here doing my own thing
um soy says that you're playing tomorrow
at 2 A.M
make my
make my chat bigger because I can't see
it
or I just need to
get better contacts or something I'm not
sure so okay
a huge thank you to creators Corp who
worked with me on this map I
like
well they brought me the idea of doing
something oh my gosh okay anyway sorry I
can't chat
because it's time
nice to meet you I'm JPEG and I help out
here on robot Ranch now I wish that I
could show you around but we've got a
little problem and time is of the
essence those lousy pests have stolen
our tractors gears RoboCop it's ready
for Harvest will you help me out and get
these years back and save robot Ranch
um yes okay this is the first time I'm
playing with other people
dude this is exciting
I don't I have like
I've got like a hamster on my back
so I guess
watch out for those pests
I guess we go
it's so cute it's so cute it's so cute
and with no jet pack oh no
[Music]
I already got crushed
splash
I don't want to talk about it I don't
want to talk about it
no I don't want to talk about it
hello oh well Renegade East yes the
hamster is so cute okay I missed all of
those
please don't go into the into the dirt
and I have crushed myself again
um the code should be in the description
it's also up at the top up there you see
it
oh my gosh not again
so I'm definitely not gonna beat my my
high score of uh 13 minutes here I can
tell also there is no try over here I
have a little struggle
thank you
man what did that mean what is that what
was that sound
what what was that
someone just talked to me
somebody cheered
oh my gosh the cable box hello my friend
watch out for that
oh yeah I I don't want to talk about it
oh my gosh that's so loud
please don't squish me
please don't squish me oh no come on you
idiot you pig
okay so this is like my first run on
not on PC so just just let me just give
me a second
[Music]
I think my next run will be better
I'm pretty sure
yep see that you got you got chopped
this is terrible
this is I am a pro I'm a pro
oh come on
it's so cute
okay I know every time I need to I need
to hide over here
well that one does its thing
okay we're home free now
we're good we're good
way to go
come on idiots
don't
do it
oh
okay look at jpeg jpeg is so cool
bouncy
big jump you're flying
yeah I'm gonna be hopping on that so
that I
can respawn there in case I die
so my problem with like obstacle courses
and speed runs and things like I want to
go so fast and then there's no time to
swim
and then uh the video is pixelated
is that my fault
oh my God my freaking thing is
it's it's moving around again
there we go
my camera
here we go here we go here we go here we
go this is the jpeg so basically jpeg
you got it
guides us through the map
well that's close call close call
close call
I'm glad they added another little
respawn right there because there used
to be one that was all the way back
and you would get set all the way back
after this
you got crushed here
look at all of you guys up there oh no
this one
this makes me cry
oh come on idiot
you pig
no oh God I wasn't ready
I'm trying to look at the chat at the
same time
uh so many of you guys want to play the
island code is
um in the description it's also up at
the top of this game
you'll see it
I don't even care that I missed those I
just wanted to get through it
this is faster than the Kessel Run
here we go making progress there used to
be some Vines right here that you'd have
to jump over and it was it was actually
it was pretty challenging so those
aren't there anymore
I almost got crushed that was a close
call
okay we're making our way we're making
our way
do you guys remember when I started the
game and I spelled fortnite wrong in the
title yeah I remember
I just want to make sure that anyone
knew joining
doesn't forget about it
okay so if you're just joining hi I'm
Justine this is my fortnite map that
just went live today it is called robot
Ranch
and
I'm so hyped about it
please okay oh my gosh I was just hoping
that was gonna show up
[Music]
here we go there's another little
gear here
I might actually
impressive like I don't know what my
time is gonna be
because at this rate
you know we're nearing we're nearing the
end
we're about a little more than halfway
through
oh that's so loud
um thank you for subscribing to all of
those
notifications that are happening
oh you guys can't see
the gear I should put myself up there
there we go okay you're way faster than
I thought
um it's also weird that
like I hear my voice in the game
if you guys have played let me know your
fastest times in
in the chat
oh
thank you Emerson Sage for the sub it's
a trap
that scared me I was not ready for that
I guess I could pick up this one last
science oh come on
cgt gaming thank you
Zach
I'm trying to get the freaking screw
[Music]
okay definitely not making any
progress on my my best time here
everyone else is probably already done
we do
you just hit in five minutes
braggy
oh this looks a little different from
the last time I played
I like okay please oh gosh oh gosh oh
gosh gosh
um yeah they've updated a few things
I misspelled fortnite again
no I didn't did I
you guys I'm on well
I blame apple season
here we go here we go here we go make it
our way
at least
hey okay the droids we're looking for
they are
that was close
Oh I thought I wasn't gonna make it
um oh thank you Caleb actually I did the
voiceover in my studio I used my podcast
setup and um
yeah I had a bunch of lines that they
suggested
to read and record and I did it and
that was it
if you guys ever find any errors or
anything just let us know
um
because no no no no no no no
the fortnite code is up there it's up on
top you'll see in the red
you can just uh
taking a little distance
taking a little dip paw
why am I just floating around the island
I'm
not sure actually
[Music]
dude I used to love streaming it was
very fun
I just
it's just everything takes so much time
lifeguard
oops
let's go we gotta we gotta we got it we
can't be doing this
we gotta step it up
so I've already
not gonna make it
well actually
I might actually make it because I'm
close to the end
no
no I'm so close to beating my time
oh my gosh whoa wasn't ready for that
you're a natural
thank you
okay well it's still 13 minutes
is super fast too this Harvest should
so there we are
I picked up a lot of them
[Music]
um okay
responded to my ad nice to meet you I'm
jpeg you should banana you should
definitely get it I wish that
YouTube Feels Like A much cleaner place
of streaming problem I guess so
um this took a few months actually
shall we go again
let's go again
yeah I'm not messing around this time
it's black oh come on
hi for those of you just joining this is
a map that I worked on with uh Creator
Corps creators Corp and they did all of
the design they did everything but it
was my idea to do robot Ranch because I
came up with this just called oh shoot
uh robot Ranch was something that was
originally going to be something
completely different and then when we
were like what should we do for a
fortnight map I was like oh you know
what it'd be super cool if
we made a ranch that has robots and I
also have another character jpig
so yeah it's it's a whole thing I missed
half of those
I'm gonna do so much better this time
because now I know
what I gotta do
yeah you guys gotta let me know your
high scores
please don't get me please don't get me
please don't get me
okay yeah we made it through that
seamless
first here
and with no jet pack
oh yeah we're making progress now kids
we spoke too soon
come on
and with no jet pack
I didn't get the
little
response I'd better not fall
um no come on
the iPhone 15 Pro Max is not forty five
thousand dollars
no deaths the entire run look I'm trying
like you think I'm trying to do bad
oh well that's close call
definitely doing better my second run
thank you Armin Armand for subscribing
appreciate it
some of you guys asking about Starfield
I am not allowing myself to play it
until after
Tech season is over
because I
know how I am with video games
and I can't
I have no self-control
so that's probably going to be
I probably be able to play it pretty
soon
everyday Jay your blue 15 per year to
get delayed so didn't mind dude I'm so
upset
mine doesn't get delivered until like
October
careful okay that I I that was not great
my robot vacuums are doing well
thank you for asking
okay
how do I feel the pink phone I I love it
it's just I wish it was a pro phone
because like
hello oh come on
oh I just got spawned into a squish Fest
foreign
how are you good to see you
how's college
I can't believe you're in college my my
kids are all grown up
oh geez I just got hit on the head
um the amount that I played Zelda
I mean definitely it's over 200 hours
so I don't know if Brie Larson played
over 200 hours of Zelda
but if she did
that's freaking awesome
I basically did nothing for
a few months this beginning of this year
is pretty rough
not gonna lie
and I put all of my
my emotions and feelings into
rounding myself in my video game playing
it's very healthy I definitely recommend
it everyone should do it
it's great
this run is going much better
um thank you Andre oh no I'm just
looking at the oh it's looking at the
chat
oh shoot
please please show up
that was like a trust fall
I've got the black titanium today nice
good job taking a little dip oh she's
come on
please show up yes
trust fall
that makes me sad
okay
I'm gonna I'm not gonna try to like I'm
just gonna Focus
and not try to be going too fast
because when I try too hard that's when
things
go wrong
like I just gotta be patient
which I have zero patients to be honest
with you
hello good to go
oh I almost missed that one
um anybody else has anybody else played
yet
I'm not playing this on switch I'm
playing this on Xbox right now
do people notice me using the phone
before I it comes out no because I'm
very careful
to make sure that they
don't see me using it
that was a much better run than
first one
let's close
we got this
progress is being made everyone
I need to see you just finished in six
minutes
okay well
I'm at eight minutes
and I'm still
see I need to
um lifeguard
I need to figure out how to be better at
this I gotta I gotta do a little bit
quicker
but I also feel like I should just be
patient
because if I try to get silly
and Wild
I end up falling in
up wasting war time
so I should probably just be patient
right
what do I do with other older models of
phones I usually send them back to Apple
but I end up buying my own so I kind of
just sort of saved them for reference
for other videos and stuff like that
here we go oh my gosh we're nearing
we're nearing the end everyone
no hole that was close call
I'm so nervous
this is where I get super nervous
because we're like
we're getting there
uh my dog is doing well Emily I can't
wait for you to play
you're gonna love it
oh man I'm so tired like we literally I
woke up at 4am didn't go to bed until
like midnight because I was working on
my launch video for this
if I do well here
no spoke too soon spoke too soon
sploosh
it's 4 20 am for you oh my gosh I'm so
sorry that's
why did I do that why did I do that I
know I know that that's
I gotta be 13 minutes
oh no come on oh my gosh oh my gosh
we're so close we're so close we're so
close we're so close
okay we're gonna be 13.
under 12. this is great this is great
this is great
and holy Robo pal you've got all of the
gears and super fast too thanks to you
this Harvest should go off without a
hitch
okay I still got a bronze okay
I think our leaderboard needs to be
updated
oh shoot okay
all right
I'm gonna back out so I can join maybe
we'll see
hey jpeg hey J Pig
I need a I need a break
okay
breathe a little bit
man I used to play fortnite so much like
season one
and season two I was obsessed and then I
stopped playing for a little while
and then when no build came back got
back into it
and then now when they're they're doing
like these Creator Maps they're so fun
like I I love them and they're such a
great idea
okay we're going back in yeah the
leaderboard is not right I'm gonna send
them a message because that's that's
definitely not right
I mean it just went live so if there is
anything
that you guys have seen that's
like not working out well
let us know
they can fix it
Alex thank you I appreciate it
I keep forgetting to look at my stream
to make sure nothing is happening like
because my camera sometimes moves around
I do still have my original iPhone and
it still works
Sparkling Ice uh he's so good
okay
oh my gosh what's that
I can't build here
we don't we don't build
yeah that's not that's not right we
gotta get that fixed
[Music]
hi hello
um
just doing a little dance here
I love the fortnite dances
so good
okay time to run
watch out for those pets okay
oh there's my basketball
what is that sound oh my God that was a
that sound scared me
what is that
bouncy
how come I miss those every single time
I also miss fortnite on the iPhone I'm
not gonna lie I also wish you could play
it on Mac
like it's
um very sad
free fortnite
like this is honestly I think this
jumping on these logs is the hardest
thing for me the game about the name of
the game is robot Ranch
fortnite
come on please please just come on be
better be better be a better person be a
better person
be better
please don't stop it
stop it oh God
okay okay okay just focus
this is I can't
can I jump a little bit no I can't
pick it a little dip
take it a little dip
and with no jet pack I miss them every
single time
yeah
what is that sound
it scares me is it these guys are they
making that sound now
they are that's new
they were not making the sound before
oh my gosh it's the most terrifying
sound
I tried to play
um instead I couldn't play season 4 on
the Mac Mac chick
Emily thank you I appreciate it
it's a Grassroots
oh come on Endeavor shoot hello um
Chelsea and Eric hi hello Emily's the
best
I just agree with whatever she says
her mom's also super cool too
and her sister whole family just the
best
like those were not making that sound
the last game were they
oh it's so terrifying
we got this
do we
truly I'm not sure
I just gotta I have to be better
swim big
okay under 10 minutes okay okay let's go
let's go let's go under 10 minutes
not starting out so strong
um lifeguard I am so mad there are some
plans for tournament cash Austin
and we're still figuring out all of the
details
yeah I'm hopping back here because I
don't want to have to do that again
no
I do I have to calm down I have to calm
down I have to calm down and calm down
for focus
10 push-ups every time I miss
honestly I should because my fitness has
been trash this year and I'm unhappy
about it so maybe that's what we need
I like that idea to go
I should have a push-up cam
I'll use my stream deck
oh
that's that makes me mad
um so any of you guys just joining hello
I'm Justine this is my fortnite map
it's called robot Ranch
I voiced the character Jake
jpeg
in the game I'm jpig I take you through
the match through the obstacle course it
is a speed run it's still new so if you
do run into any glitches or anything
just uh let us know
we literally it just launched today but
so far everything has been running
pretty smooth
I'm super happy with it the island code
is above
so come and play I'm going to be doing a
longer stream tomorrow
I just kind of wanted to do like a
little launch stream today just because
you gotta
I also want to figure out
I don't know I just
need to be better
um
[Music]
there's no time to swim
there isn't time soon because I want to
if I want to play this if I want to beat
this in under 10 minutes
okay
a perfect dive
the first time I played this
not not the finished map but this one I
literally could not jump get past this
one
bouncy
missed a few of
the cave
help me fortniteer you're my only hope
Little Star Wars reference
I love the hamster so much I've had that
for quite a while and I just got this
new the new bare skin
thank you Keenan tech reviews appreciate
it thanks for the sub
okay that's good we made that we made
that through quick
good positioning for this one
I'm not gonna like mess around I'm just
gonna Focus
good positioning for this one as well
oh gosh I was jumped
sploosh
no
okay we got this we got this we got some
thoughts we got this
that was Pure Luck
I was just hoping that it would show up
[Music]
you got it
I did
taking a little no you idiot this is
just precious time precious time
precious time I've wasted for dumb
mistakes
precious time
precious
okay you're way faster than I thought
thank you Justin I mean jpeg
oh yeah we're crushing it
not gonna make it under 10 minutes
[Music]
lasered oh come on
Thank You singer Savannah it is also my
favorite color
okay there wasn't anything there
I'm just gonna preemptively jump then
we can't risk it
impressive
thank you aruman Arun uh I can't read
that Aruna Aruna day a ruin of my day
I'm not going to fall on here
okay I can drink my Sparkle ice while we
spin
you probably have a million outfits but
we're the same thing often I do I
literally wear I have a uniform
yoga pants Aviator Nation
and like the same Rag and Bone like
striped shirts I mean
it's really the way to do it this is
farming
now this is farming I also had a cold
when I was recording the vo for this
I'm finally just getting over it
like we're already 11 minutes this is
how did that happen like how did I do so
bad
we might as well finish it this is for
here
but
oh they're going fast
what was like do you guys remember my
last time it was like 10 minutes
something
I should have wrote it down because I
think our scoreboard is broken oops pass
up our entrance
sploosh
I got I gotta I gotta be better
I wonder
I wonder what the fastest time is so far
gotta find out
and who has the fastest time
that will be the question
who's it gonna be
I know somebody uh one of you guys said
that you had six minutes
very impressive
pretty impressive
this is not a good run
[Music]
okay we gotta get under 10 minutes
guys stop fighting about whatever you
guys are fighting about
on the chat
everything here is cool fast too still
bronze
um okay let's go again ready
thank you Debbie
watch out for those pests
we're going again
I'm waiting to let PES goes by
I kind of like the noise now because it
gives you a little heads up
oh no not this again not this again
I got this i got this I'm not messing it
up
look at that look at that like a true no
jet
champion
ah a scary little noise
oh so close
I haven't died yet did I did I die I
don't know I'm not sure I've lost track
you hear her flying dude we're doing
we're we actually are flying this time
whoa
no
oh God my neighbors I I truly don't know
how they haven't called the cops yet on
me
when I play video games
oh yeah we are moving and grooving
moving and growing God guys we're
grooving
we got this
I don't want to go yet because I feel
like it's gonna
oh I'm so scared I'm so scared
it was a close call
oh man oh man I just I'm gonna get
crushed oh that was so close
a brush a brush with death
you hear her flying no come on oh my
gosh oh my God okay okay dude we're
doing so good this time
like everything is working out
everything is working out great
I'm sweating
like I'm actually starting to sweat
like we're cruising
foreign
stoked
no
I was reading the chat
please please please show up
you make me so mad
okay we got this we got this we got this
we got this I got I gotta pay a little
closer attention
to the timing
please please show up thank you thank
you
um thank you senior Savannah
appreciate it
impressive
yeah I know
phew few few few
[Music]
I mean look at we're like okay we're
four or five minutes
hello concept creator
good to see you it's been a while how
the heck have you been
what are you up to
like I'm jumping over all of these
because I'm not risking it like it's
it's not worth it
[Music]
like I don't care
way to go
thank you
less stress at the moment okay that's
good but decent I've I've been decent I
mean it's iPhone season so I'm
physically mentally emotionally
exhausted
and we had the game launched so
everything has just been
happening all at once but it's all good
man
you know this year sucked but
we're making do
we're making deal
I got I have to
I have to not fall
yeah I was basically I edited my entire
iPhone 15 review while traveling
thankfully Tyler was working on the
iPhone 15. I worked on the pro
so we had both of those videos ready to
go
for uh day one it was
it was wild
[Music]
dude I'm I'm focusing so hard
like my brain is starting to hurt
7 24.
get it oh my God I'm wasting precious
seconds
I'm playing on Xbox
okay
whoa that was nice
that really gave me a little boost
you're so stupid you're so stupid
you're so stupid
I'm so nervous
oh
under 10 under we might even get under
nine
you're a natural oh shoot
yes yes yes let's go let's go let's go
yes I read viewers comments but I'm in
the middle of playing a game I can't
read the tractor all mixed up 8 45 okay
8 45 okay that's that's the best time so
far for me
silver
let's go
wow
oh shoot okay hold on a second I need to
do some things over here oh my God we
have a hype train
okay one second here
just making sure all of the things are
good
[Music]
I feel pretty good
okay I'm gonna play oh my gosh I was
supposed to be
voice volume yeah we want that
I can't believe okay what was what was
my time 8 45 is that our best time
I think
that was pretty decent I'm gonna try to
do a better
Baldur's Gate three I don't know what
that is so I'm not sure if I'll play it
I don't know
I don't know what that is but I'll check
it out
ggs
okay so what is everyone else's fastest
time because I've seen one of you guys
said
uh uh you said six minutes
pretty good
pretty impressed
foreign
looking to see if you guys have any
screenshots
of your times
please screenshot them to me if you do
have them
okay
look at my little sad tractor
watch out for those pests
yeah I'm aware
man that sound totally helps thank you
rohits rohits oh that one huh oh come on
no that's not good
that's hurting my time already
okay I'm gonna
jump I'm upset
so I'm gonna I'm gonna just go back out
because I'm that type of person
foreign
because this is going to be it
this is gonna be
it's gonna be it guys I'm gonna do so
well this time
I'm gonna do so well
am I
am I also streaming on YouTube
if I
if I stream to YouTube as well
and I didn't realize it
you guys
um I am so sorry YouTube commenters
I did not know that I was streaming to
YouTube as well
I'm so shook right now
I am absolutely shook to my core the
fact that I did not know
like
I can't
believe I can't believe it
you guys I am so
I'm so shook and I've been ignoring
YouTube guys I didn't
I was not reading YouTube comments
hi Katie no I wasn't
you
just streamlab shows both
I was wondering because I was looking
because there was like a little fight
happening in the chat
and I was like well I don't see this
happening on Twitch I'm so confused
maybe the chat is just lagged
I can't believe it
so then
I am and now my freaking camera is
going crazy again
I'm not made for this I'm not made for
this world
flower
I'm absolutely just shook
okay
so now I'm streaming on both
now I'm in the
multi-stream
you guys this is unbelievable
this is unbelievable
[Music]
didn't even know
we love that so I've been reading your
comments the the top of the thing
that I'm looking at on the comments
says YouTube and that's why when Emily
said something about I don't think
there's any mods on I was like well yeah
you guys are all mods on Twitch I don't
understand
what a surprise
[Music]
ice cream cheese okay so I'm streaming
on both
yeah because
oh my God well
we're here now
so oh my God this is so wild this is so
exciting
and you're what you have some of you
guys are watching on both thanks for
ignoring us no I think I was I've been
talking to YouTube for the last hour
I was thinking I was talking to Twitch
it's Twitter for me it's always Twitter
it'll always be Twitter it's
I
now I'm stressed out
I'm just gonna do another run
I also can't breathe my allergies are
terrible I'm a mess
I can't believe you guys I am so
surprised right now and that I didn't
even realize
that I've been reading YouTube comments
for the last hour
whole time thought of a switch
that is psychotic behavior
like that's that's how much um that's
how much of a noob I am no I would okay
I didn't ghost you on YouTube I think
I've been I think I've been talking to
YouTube the whole time
is that I think I ghosted twitch even
though I told everyone to come watch on
Twitch and then I ignored them
I thought I was reading all of your
comments
what do you know anyway I appreciate all
of you from wherever you're watching
because when I went to start streaming
it said something like
you have to enter YouTube credentials
I'm like oh I don't feel like figuring
that out right now so I just
I just clicked twitch well it's
surprised surprise
what a treat what a treat
oh hey
way to go
bouncy
whoosh
well I'm gonna Focus now because I
really want to get a good time
um I I I still am so shook at the fact
that
nobody told me I was streaming on both
platforms
but that
no idea
I stream so infrequently
that every time I have to like set my
stream up I have to start from scratch
and then everything's all messed up
so it's just it's a hot mess
and it wouldn't be an iJustine stream
without everything being so chaotic I
think I need
I need to have like a professional
streamer come in and just be like look
what you're doing is not right the setup
is
you have the things to make a good
stream why are you not doing it
I don't know I'm
I'm unsure but all I know is we're gonna
get a good time this time
I can feel it we're starting out strong
jump I can stay on these shrooms
you hear her fly okay great great we are
flying
and hopefully
shoot I just missed it I just missed the
boat
okay you're way faster than I thought
so then people subscribing to me
I've been saying thanks for the
subscription is that on YouTube or is
that on don't even know where it is
really don't even know
somebody said vtube is jpeg I don't know
how to do that but like that sounds like
an incredible idea I'm obsessed with it
I'm sure I can figure it out
I love that so much
cream cheese hello okay so that's on
YouTube
more Vlogs please okay so you said that
on Twitch I've got them both open now
oh my goodness this is so silly
I can't look at the chat right now
because
All I do is win win no matter what
please be please show up I just pray
that the platform pops up when it needs
to
please please please show up oh my God
that was a beautiful that timing was
impeccable
it truly was it was a true gift
from the fortnite gods
so when I spelled fortnite wrong at the
beginning of the stream and I I fixed it
is it still spelled wrong on YouTube
the questions I think I only fixed it on
Twitch
[Music]
I can't believe you some of you guys are
watching on both like you're
it's wrong on YouTube oh my goodness
that's why when you said or do not there
is no trouble
when you guys said it was wrong I go no
I changed it
yeah change it on Twitch
can't believe it
it's classic it is
classic I just seen streaming Behavior
wouldn't be a stream without it
but dude we're cruising now
sub 8 sub 8.
it's getting sweaty
I'm just gonna I have to stay calm
because I'm not gonna
like I could jump on these to get there
faster but I just I'm afraid I'm just
gonna be patient
the reactions relayed versus the video
really
oh I have so many problems
I think my video is also delayed I think
it's this webcam that I have
spelled wrong by earlier announcement
video oh my gosh
I was doing like 500 things at the time
whatever
you know what I meant
help me for you know what I meant you're
my only hope
okay I don't think we're gonna be
getting under
eight
like I can't mess up at all
where'd all those bugs go the pests
there was there used to be some over
there
maybe they took a little a little break
yeah tomorrow I'll have a little bit
more time during the day to kind of set
up and perfect the stream and switch out
like with a decent camera I mean I like
my camera that I have but I wanna I
wanna switch it to a Sony
okay we're doing it
shoots no because like 8 45 was my best
like there's no way I'm gonna be able to
make it over there
so that's really sad for me
just swim there isn't
I wonder if tomorrow I'll stream on both
platforms by accident
oh sure just walk off walk right off
walk right off there why don't why don't
you do that
you fool
now I'm just so stressed from
from what I did
nine minutes okay we're under ten so
that's great
impressive
what time it might be going on tomorrow
I don't know I I am not sure because I'm
probably gonna go to jiu jitsu first and
then
stream in the afternoon sometime so
we'll see the announcement video Don't
Say fortnite
and fortnite that's great that's cool we
love that we love we love spelling
mistakes
um
let's see can I go back to my web
here it is it's right up there two eight
four four five one zero four five two
nine two I've also posted about it on
Twitter and on Instagram and on YouTube
so
no sound
[Music]
I swear to you
I just
what I said that you probably didn't
hear is that I don't stream that often
so uh there's a lot of chaos that
happens and I will be streaming tomorrow
but this is
a super fun map I'm so excited about if
you guys want to play the island code is
above it's on Twitter it's on Instagram
I basically posted it everywhere and
we don't hear anything
[Music]
hello
you can hear it
can you not hear me
this makes me so sad
it says you could hear me
anyway type pig in the chat type pig in
the chat
if you see it
or hear me
you can hear on the screen
okay well I'll fix that let me
whatever
um
so my best time is 8 45 here on robot
Ranch thank you guys so much for
watching thank you concept creator for
hanging out thank you everyone Emily
campus Mania Matthew talks with world I
can go okay um rohot uh Matthew elon's
musk okay here's the multi-stream chat
this is great I can see everything
I can see it all
this is this is what we'll do tomorrow
thank you again for watching again if
you want to play the island code is
28445-104-5292 let me know your best
scores send me screenshots to my Twitter
or Instagram or post some Recaps on
Twitter or on Tick Tock if you'd like
but I look forward to playing with you
guys and I will stream again tomorrow so
I will talk to you guys soon thank you
guys so much YouTube and twitch
um
pretty hyped about that
I like my basketball